what can we as Catholics do now to
combat radical gender ideology with how
far it has gone start by just being
skeptical about everything you hear from
these people and being willing to ask
questions another thing that we can do
and we should all be doing is going to
our churches going to our pastors and
saying to them you know we need you to
take a leadership role on this issue we
need you to speak out about this we need
to hear from you on this as laypeople we
shouldn't have to be in the position of
telling pastors and Priests
that they need to lead us but
unfortunately we do because what I have
found is that the vast majority of
churches are you know sort of punting on
this issue entirely they don't want to
talk about it as Catholics we live every
day in this increasingly insane culture
that's falling into the abyss and then
we kind of claw away to church every
Sunday and we sit down we're kind of
bruised and battered and broken and we
need to hear someone who speaks to the
reality that we're living in every day
and that's oftentimes not what we hear